great first quarter great first half
again and a
record setting performance as we send it
to jared greenberg
yeah another night b.a and another luca
doncic record
tonight you have surpassed the likes of
kareem abdul-jabbar the most
points in nba history over your first
two career playoff games
when you hear that what do you think
about i mean we gotta win
that's all i care about you know i think
i mean that's great stats you know but
we gotta win i knew we could get a win i
know
we can we are able to fight these guys
and you know we show up today
speaking of fight we were wondering if
you were going to fight your coach a
couple of times tonight because
of the foul trouble you didn't seem
happy to be coming out of the game how
frustrating was it that you were only
able to play 28 minutes tonight
i mean it was frustrating you know i
just want to get out there help my team
you know i was pissed
i ate some unnecessary things you know i
shouldn't do
but you know we gotta win uh that's all
it matters and you know
a lot of a lot of guys showed up i know
we played great defense
and that's what we have to do all right
well coming up after us is
inside the nba and we know that you last
night were tweeting about the show
so assuming you're going to rush back to
your hotel room to watch ernie charles
shaq and kenny
what should they be saying about luca
doncic and the dallas mavericks tonight
i mean this they should be saying uh we
got a chance you know
in this first round you know a lot of
people i say counter sign you know
i read a lot of people didn't count the
same but i know they should be saying
you know we got a chance
and the thing about dallas you know
we're going to give everything 100 we're
going to live
the heart on the court and i think
that's that's the point for us
that's interesting you may have just
taken charles the spot he might not have
to do the show
no no he's better he's better and shaq
wants everybody to call bobon
you rang that's what he wants from
behind the adams family
you got to call him urang from now on
luke congratulations thank you series ba
is tied up at one and one
yes it is and the moral of the story all
nba players you wear a live microphone
during the game
good things i know you won big games in
europe
how does it feel to get your first nba
playoff team
it was great you know we tied the series
like i said when i
came here you know we better move uh
today
and you know we just got three left and
i think we can fight for it it's just a
series you guys can win
well yeah for sure i mean any seriously
we're gonna we're gonna go and
we're gonna believe that we can win for
sure if you
if you don't believe it uh you're not
supposed to be here so you're gonna
believe every time
one more in the room here it's uh mark
what do you think it's to be able to
play through the frustration of
physicality and foul calls and all that
still
played again something you get used to
it
you know i still get a gotta do a better
job doing that
but it's something you're gonna get used
to it you know i already experienced
that in here
uh you know it's gonna be every game
like this and you just gotta get used to
it
and be okay with it
okay tim mcmahon
luke after you picked up your fifth foul
there in the uh opening seconds of the
fourth quarter
what was it like for you sitting there
on the bench
i'm sure frustrated but watching your
teammates be able to maintain that lead
oh yeah i was frustrated for like
15 seconds then you know i was i was
focused you know i was good at
uh support my teammates you know they
did a great great job
you know just being there i mean being
on a bench it's hard for me you know
when i help my team
but you know we won the game maybe if i
don't pick that foul we don't win the
game so it's a name next up is todd
hey look uh then when you did come back
in the game late
later on uh you know how did it feel to
be able to close out this game after
everything you guys have went through
and
in uh struggling to close out games
earlier in the season
oh yeah i think we're way more locked in
you know
we can give up lips like leads like that
but it was great feeling you know we won
the second game so we died it was an
amazing feeling you know to win a
playoff game
okay last one in english is dave
mcmenamin
luka when you look at the box score
tonight and you see in the turnover
category just one uh what how do you
feel
uh that was the only thing i looked up
you know one turnover it was great
you know that's what i was looking for
and i told you it's like
it's 10 possessions more than the last
game so that's why
that's one of the reasons we won
okay we'll move over to spanish eugenio
hola luca felicidades victoria
is
[Music]
is
is
okay luca we'll let you go thank you
everybody my apologies if i wasn't able
to get to your quest